you're seated or to zero in feel you
would be on a overrun line to perform
the duties listed on the safety career
stop that you can break away those don't
write them so how's the drink well it's
not a very strong drink just don't tell
anyone
oh that feels good [ __ ] I'm telling you
my dogs are barking that hey holy [ __ ]
say your prayers
everybody's strapped in about the open
some [ __ ] window
because a chips think he's handsome B
has cool car C has lots of cash
first for his back
I just want to tell you both good luck
we're all counting on you has anyone
seen Bruce Willis this happy in decades
the guy needs to start drinking the wine
coolers again look at him he's going
crazies loves it he's singing oh man
start drinking the wine coolers again
Bruce